thank you secretary general it is a
privilege to join the global forum for
children and youth
during the climate summit in glasgow a
young filipino activist said
i think world leaders hear us
but i don't think they listen to us
and sadly this is too often the case
our goal today must be to act on young
people's concerns
this is what we are doing in europe
i want the year 2022
to be the european year of youth to
honor support and engage with young
people
to make them central to all european
union policies social digital or climate
this year we presented the european
strategy on the rights of the child
to protect
promote
and fulfill basic rights of young people
to improve quality education at home and
abroad
and i joined the secretary general's
call to all leaders
to step up pledges and commitments
to fill the funding gap widened by covet
19.
in the coming six years the european
union will devote over 6 billion euro
to improving education in africa latin
america and asia some 13
of our development assistants
let us give each and every child the
chance of a better future
it is the best and most rewarding
investment you can think of